c'est juste
avoir ça en ayant la passion et l'aimer
et ensuite travailler pour ça
[Musique] [
Musique]
à l'école primaire, je jouais au
basket
et la fois où je suis allé regarder des matchs et j'ai
vu des gens à l'intérieur du terrain de jeu, ils les
appelaient arbitre et  J'étais ravi de
savoir comment ces gens qu'ils
font, ils peuvent prendre des décisions, ils peuvent
tout changer à l'intérieur du terrain de
jeu, donc
je suis excité par ces gens qui
les voyaient à l'intérieur du terrain de jeu à
l'école secondaire maintenant, j'ai dit, laissez-moi sauter
dans les choses et puis c'est là que le
voyage a commencé
[Music]
ont été changés d'une carrière à
une autre carrière football et maintenant
c'était très très difficile je ne savais pas qu'il
y avait beaucoup à faire il y a des lois à
suivre
il y a un
mentalité à suivre il y a un
professionnalisme à l'intérieur
donc à partir de ce moment je commence à apprendre
pas à pas donc
maintenant me voilà
[Musique] [
Musique]
soirée on
a notre période
parfois tu ne peux pas courir
tu ne peux pas  pour officier nous devons
accoucher
nous avons besoin de temps pour récupérer quelque chose d'autre
certains pays ne donnent pas aux femmes
des parts égales pour jouer au football ou pour être
arbitres donc c'est l'obstacle ce sont
des défis
nous avons travaillé très dur
parce que
beaucoup disent  les femmes, elles ne peuvent pas courir
à la vitesse des hommes et peu importe,
oui,
nous ne pouvons pas être des hommes,
mais nous pouvons
faire de notre mieux pour être au même niveau
[Musique]
j'ai beaucoup d'expérience dans
toutes ces compétitions,
donc ça  signifie que je n'ai rien changé j'ai
fait ce que j'avais
l'habitude de faire
je n'ai pas fait quelque chose de différent
en disant que c'est euh je suis parti alors maintenant je
vais changer ma mentalité je vais
changer la façon d'officier non
c'était le  même
[Musique]
je suis maintenant professionnellement libre payé c'est l'
occasion que nous avons
maintenant d'ouvrir la porte et de montrer que
toutes les femmes africaines elles sont capables
elles peuvent atteindre ce stade nous
ne sommes pas ici parce que
nous avions la faveur d'être ici
c'est juste le hasard
ce n'est pas
parce que nous méritons d'être ici nous devons
créer un moyen
de voir beaucoup de femmes non seulement pour les
femmes en afghan peut-être que nous voulons voir
cinq
jerome pourquoi pas dix
inshallah
[Musique]
vous